[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
que peut la douane face au trafic de
stupéfiants
avec 60 à 80% des saisies de produits
stupéfiants sur le territoire national
la douane et l'administration en
première ligne face au trafic de drogue
en 2021 la douane a saisi 115 tonnes de
produits stupéfiants l'évolution de ces
résultats reste difficile à interpréter
les saisies augmentent-elles parce que
l'efficacité des services douaniers
s'accroix ou parce que les flux de
produits stupéfiants augmentent aussi
pour y voir plus clair albéric de
Montgolfier et Claude Mougins rapporteur
spéciaux de la mission gestion des
finances publiques ont présenté les
conclusions de leur contrôle budgétaire
sur l'organisation et les moyens de la
douane face au trafic de stupéfiants
la douane est appelée à renforcer ses
missions en la matière dans la menace
liée à ce trafic ne cesse de s'accroître
avec des flux toujours plus dynamiques
et de multiples vecteurs d'entrées sur
le territoire le vecteur terrestre est
le plus fréquemment utilisé pour le
trafic de résine de cannabis notamment
en provenance d'Espagne et d'héroïnes
par la route des Balkans les flux
aériens sont propices au transport de
multiples catégories de stupéfiants
enfin une tendance récente inquiète les
services douaniers le contournement des
voies traditionnelles par le recours aux
fraises express et postale
les rapporteurs de la commission des
finances ont tenu à inscrire leur
recommandation dans le cadre du contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens de la douane
pour la période 2022 à 2025 ce contrat
prévoit un effort supplémentaire de 148
millions d'euros pour les dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'investissement de la
douane
97 millions d'euros seront alloués à des
dépenses d'équipement dans ce cadre
contrainte les rapporteurs défendent des
mesures de gestion visant à allouer à
budget global constant plus de moyens à
l'acquisition de matériel performants et
à la modernisation des systèmes
d'information une réorganisation des
effectifs est également nécessaire
dans une logique de performance des
services les rapporteurs préconisent en
outre de valoriser davantage la collecte
et l'exploitation des données pour un
meilleur ciblage des contrôles au-delà
des saisies de drogues il faut également
s'intéresser aux flux financier pour
pouvoir frapper les organisations
criminelles sur leur vulnérabilité à
cette fin les sénateurs recommandent un
renforcement de la coopération tant au
niveau des différentes administrations
qu'au niveau européen
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]